[Music]
It's never happened in the history
of the world that technology has advanced at
such a speed, and the result is that
all global social structures
are being turned upside down.
I don't think we
can continue like this. That's the subject of
my book, "The Century of Threats." We ca
n't continue like this. It won't
continue like this. It will continue like this. It won't
continue like this. Whatever
our leaders, from whatever party, say, there's
nothing to be done. Humanity is heading for disaster,
and there's nothing we can do about it. And that's
the kind of consideration that
escapes the public.
[Music]
Completely more productivism or
consumerism can't cure the words
of consumerism. More can't cure
the words of
[Music]
consumption. And I'm not for
the Apocalypse, the
catastrophe. I'm simply saying, here's the
situation. It's very simple: you have
a finite quantity of resources
[Music],
and this finite quantity will be
consumed sooner or later.
[Music]
There's a lot of controversy, people
who say, but no, not  Not at all, it'll all work out.
So we say man has
always managed, that's the
classic reasoning, we've always
found solutions, we'll manage.
So people who talk about exhaustion are
wrong.
[Music]
Laovere is here, but I don't think it's
true. We're in an
unprecedented situation. We can't say man has
always managed. Today it's not
[Music]
true.
Shortages will be aggravated by science and
technology, contrary to what we
think. And so it's true, but what
happened is that the machine went
haywire. Nobody thought when I was
24, nobody thought the
machine would go haywire.
[Music]
Yes, I will leave this world where action is
not the sister of R.
[Music]